hello everyone is welcome to today's
webinar how a complete set of software
and validation tools for my complete
readers can help gmpgl pee labs meet FDA
data integrity guidelines i am michelle
ashton of labyrinth and I'll be your
moderator for today's events today's
educational web seminar is presented by
laborat and brought to you by molecular
devices to learn more about our sponsor
please visit value of del UW molecular
devices calm now let's get started
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at anytime you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send will answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation click on the
support tab found at the top right of
the presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen this presentation is
educational and best offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of the presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credit
I now present today's speaker dr. Thomas
Hanks tell software product manager at
molecular devices and Sally Higham
Account Manager at molecular devices for
the complete biographies on our speakers
please visit biography tab at the top of
your screen our speakers and I'll begin
their presentations
so Thank You Michelle for the nice
introduction and welcome everyone to
today's webinar about software
compliance for microplate readers in GMP
and GOP labs so this webinar is going to
be about soft mix Pro molecular devices
product for compliance and we are doing
this webinar in regards to the Windows 7
end of life which is approaching at
January 2020 so the menu for today is an
overview about soft mix per standard in
GXP for all of our attendees who have
not used our software then we will go in
detail into the new features of our soft
mix pro 7.1 and as a third part my
colleague Shelly will introduce you to
our complete compliance offering because
compliance does in on a microplate
reader system does not only rely on the
software but there is also a wealth of
service products that are focusing on
our Hardware side
so let's get started right away with a
brief introduction about what softmax
pro is so soft mix Pro is molecular
devices multimode reader control
software and cosmic spur really does
three things
it's a project management tool so you
can use our software to manage your
complete project every single experiment
then it's obviously also the data
acquisition part where you type in your
wavelengths your bandwidth and so on and
finally when you have acquired the data
it also serves you as a data analysis
program with the capability comparable
to for instance the prism soft mix Pro
offers you an interface to your
automation and it also provides an
interface to your lymph system with the
elaborate import and expert capabilities
if you have a brief look at the software
itself on the left hand side you can see
the project management section so all
the experiments you are doing in the
project on our multimode readers you can
gather in a single file it helps you to
keep the overview about the experiments
that have been done
second you use it as a data acquisition
software so you type in your parameters
you define your plate format you define
the wavelength depend width and maybe
even my kinetic cycle after you have
acquired the data toughness Pro offers
you a wealth of data analysis tools for
instance curve fits standard deviations
and even more elaborate statistical
tools as for instance outlier tests
or our users and customers in compliance
labs that have to follow guidelines such
as the FDA 21 CFR part 11 softmax Pro XP
basically adds an additional layer of
security and protection around
software's Pro standards while the
control tools remain the same we now add
our compliance features which are user
administration system audit trail
signatures document status and
seven-point-one validation package and
an SQL database the very brief overview
about the features which we will have a
look in detail after this presentation
number one is the difference to
softworks per standard is that we are
storing documents in a SQL database the
reason for that is because it allows us
to keep full control of what's happening
to the file so we basically create a
closed system here we add the capability
of L adding electronic signatures and
statements to documents as well as the
inbuilt user administration which you
can also add to the Windows Active
Directory system and an elaborate system
audit trail that records everything that
is done in the software in detail
the document workflow system is new in
7.1 and it drives to what establishing a
paperless system in your company where
you can
we develop a protocol use it and approve
it without needing to establish a paper
trail for that we will have a look at
that in detail also later so what are
all the new features in soft whisper 7.1
and more importantly where do we even
have a new soft mix Pro 7.1 the features
not only extend to the cheeks P part but
also to the standards but in this
presentation we will mostly focus on the
cheeks P features so in 2016 a new data
integrity guideline was released by the
FDA this was a proposal and it was
finalized in 2018 but the changes were
very minor so this is why we refer to it
as the 2016 tech 30 guideline direct
quotes from this guideline are that
backup data is exact and complete secure
from operation in advertent ratios or
loss to be prevented
and the output should be checked for
accuracy
of them more
if data should be stored to prevent
deterioration
documented at a time of performance this
refers to raw data
and the record should be refute
accuracy completeness and compliance
with the established standard
and finally they should be checked
verified and refilled
is a very elaborate guideline and I'm
not going to explain every detail what
I'm explaining the rest of the
presentation is how the individual
requests from this guide line are
addressed in software's Pro 7 point so
first of all as I mentioned files are
stored in Microsoft SQL database on the
right side you see a picture how the
file system looks in this database and
as you notice it doesn't look that much
different from regular from a regular
bin this file system our software
development developers have done their
best to basically adapt the look and
feel of the database to a Windows file
system to make the switchover as easy
and comfortable as possible
but the benefits of storing files in the
database actually striking because in
previous versions the files were stored
in one in a Windows file based system
you had to apply third-party tools to
monitor renaming of the files deletion
and also moving
by storing files in the database
you
can keep complete control over files
that are being deleted and you can set
permissions to delete files so pretty
much everything that is done that has
been done on the windows level can now
be done within softmax Pro this
establishes a closed system and
massively reduces the support from your
local IT department because file
permissions are now controlled within
softmax pro and Cheeks the admin
the system audit trail
allows you to
record everything that is happening in
softmax pro in in a very close detail so
if a new table is created if the user
logs in pretty much anything that is
happening in your soft mix Pro system is
recorded in the audit trail the audit
trail itself is also stored in the SQL
database and this is not document based
anymore so all data goes into the
database squared is securely stored from
alteration so you don't need any more
third-party tools
to keep the overview we have extensive
filtering options so you can filter by
event by user by time and by document
now the core piece
our workflow --ss of our new version is
the workflow system
it provides the basis for a paperless
system
it helps the QC and the lab manager to
see at which stage document is and what
the next steps are
and it helps to prevent that lab
technicians are using documents that are
still under development so how does the
system now work I will start on a very
left hand side a typical document
lifecycle is that a scientist within a
company developed the protocol so this
scientist will develop the data
acquisition part and the data analysis
method additionally as with the paper
document where you add signature lines
we add statements the statements
indicate who should sign basically the
statements and for what reason so the
scientist would add four statements in
this example
which are getting signed all the way
till the end of the document lifecycle
after the scientist has set everything
up we change the status now to review
pending
in the review pending status the lab
manager can review the document
if you see statement one is already
signed this means that the document is
protected indicated by the little P in
the status if the lab manager would like
to change something he changes the
status back to in work and the
scientists can correct it if the
document now is reviewed and complete he
would change the add lab manager would
add his signature to statement number
two proving that he has refused the
document and promoted to refute for
simplicity the next step is also
conducted by the lab manager but could
in theory be conducted by for instance
the QC Department the QC Department then
would basically open the document in the
refute status and would release it there
is a separate button in soft mix Pro to
release the document in the same at the
same time if this is an existing
document one could theoretically update
the previous version the green document
in the middle is now the release status
we have built in another level of
security which is the Commission
generate compliance data
if you would like to move from the left
side to the right side into the
compliance area you need to have this
permission and in theory only the lab
technician should have that so once the
lab technician basically opens up the
copy of the release document statement
number two number one we're moving to
the audit trail making the document
editable in terms of being able to add
data what the lab tech can do within
this document is tightly controlled by
the permission
the NOS the lab tech would essentially
acquire the data and sign the third
statement proving that he was the one
who acquired the data the lab tech lab
manager then once again would open up
the document and refuse please note that
whenever a statement is signed so a
signatures editor documented
automatically protected so nobody can
modify it anymore
finally the lab manager would sign the
fourth statement proving that he has
refute the data and the document is
approved
in order to maintain such a workflow
system one needs a user administration
because to maintain this workflow system
we need a administrator who creates the
individual accounts we need a scientist
a lab manager and the lab technician we
all have different roles and permissions
as well as in order to enter Softimage
projects P you need to log in in
previous versions we only had the
classical user administration system
within cheeks P admin but for 7.1 you
can connect your users to the Active
Directory system this means you can sign
in with your Windows credentials please
don't mix this up with single sign-on so
this means you always have to enter your
username as your password
this this lock mean that you
automatically signed it
the benefits of having such an Active
Directory system is that it simplifies
defining password criteria because
they're determined on a company level
but if you don't want to use Active
Directory we have also expanded the
password definition criteria for 7.1
another improvement is the autosave
functionality
first of all we have upgraded the
inbuilt
autosave functionality meaning new
documents must be saved before they can
be modified so when you click new
document it immediately asks you for
name and the storage location
prevents that there are any documents
lost or any data
and autosave in this respect now means
that the scientists can already
predefined the file name as well as the
file location in the database so the lab
tech really doesn't need to define
anything anymore only need to open the
document acquire the data and sign the
statement
we have updated our signing process this
means that on the left side and on the
right side of the workflow
only one statement can be signed per
user this means that the lab manager can
only sign one statement on the left as
well as the right side preventing double
sign
we have also eliminated the need to
revoke signatures
we have extended the permission settings
to revoke users own signature but we
have also remained with the permission
to remove other people's signatures in
case somebody leaves the company but it
doesn't need to be used because you can
always create a copy of the original
using the save as comment so there is no
need anymore to revoke somebody else's 6
check
to simplify project management we have
also defined projects within GXP admin
this means that if you have a team that
is working on a specific drugs instance
you can create a project and within this
project you are assigning team members
and these team members you're assigning
a role in the example below you have
user 1 2 & 3 & ec users are assigned
roles scientist lab technician and lab
manager within this project please note
that users can have different roles in
different projects but cannot have
different roles within the same
the user can always only be assigned
once with a single role to a project you
may change his role within the project
but you cannot have two roles in the
project
for our new users we have massively
reduced the time to get started with
softmax pro by defining factory roles
these roles we have defined to test of
our knowledge so you can readily start
it with software project if by basically
understanding the workflow and using the
shown roles
for our more experienced users
offer the opportunity to create new
roles as well as to modify the factory
roles if this is desired
to improve the connectivity to lymph
systems as well as various archiving
systems we have redefined the auto
export functionality
as well as for users of the stickman
software we have implemented signed XML
files to increase data integrity and
these signed XML files can then be
important to this Beckman software
export functionalities are the export of
PDF documents CSV and essentially all
the formats you are able to export in
previous soft mix progressions the other
export function always export a copy of
the document out of the database the
original document will always remain
within the database in order to maintain
its status
new data analysis option in Softimage
Pro 7.1 are the outlier tests we have
added a route outlier test which enables
you to determine outliers based on the
curve fit and not individual data points
this has been brought to our attention
by large pharma company who has been
noted by the FDA that outlier tests are
done under under random and not defined
basis and this provides a statistical
mean to exclude outliers in soft mix
products we have also added the
capability of doing Custom Fit adding
the last level of complexity by giving
you the opportunity to find any curve
that you would like
we have edit graphs confidence bands as
shown on the right side
now would like to introduce you to my
colleague Sally who will explain our
complete portfolio of services as well
as additional products to you to really
stay in compliance with your complete
reader system including the software and
the hardware thanks Sally
you tell
so what we're going to look at now is
the path to compliance on a microplate
reader
first year it begins with the busy
delivery of components typically this
includes your microplate reader and self
maxpro GXP
space software contains everything
that's required to set up your plate
reader software for FDA's 21 CFR part 11
compliant work self match Pro GXP can be
set up on a standalone computer with or
without network access or as a network
based enterprise solution our
application scientists and technical
support team will join you remotely to
walk you through the installation on a
single computer joyed server or separate
servers
next step to look at is installation
qualification operational qualification
and preventive maintenance or IQ oq p.m.
services
of maxpro validation package provides
comprehensive documentation and tools to
validate softmax pro software and GXP
admin features the spectra test ABS 1f
l1l m1 and multimode validation plates
provide automated comprehensive and
traceable validation of microplate
reader performance for absorbance
fluorescence luminescence and other read
modes on a daily basis modes like
time-resolved fluorescence and
fluorescence polarization
are performed using the multimode plate
and the tests include accuracy
reproducibility wavelength accuracy and
so on
our tools perform plate based our phase
in a compliance environment at the same
time as consistent quality day-to-day
performance verification using spectra
test plates annual preventive
maintenance visit by our service and
early plate recertification and shall
continue performance of your reader
for further information please visit
molecular devices comm where you can
find softmax pro GXP installation guide
and release notes also a fake use are
supported by our field application
scientists and technical support teams
now we're going to open the lines up for
some questions from the audience
thank you Tom and Sally for your
informative presentations you will
notice the poll question appear on your
screens asking if you would like the
molecular devices scheme to follow up
with you to arrange a personal
demonstration if you like what you have
seen today want to find out more please
click yes
we will now start a live Q&A portion of
the webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen will answer as
many questions as we have time for now
let's get started
our first question is
can you use SQLite or must be the full
SQL server version
hi Michelle thank you so
as my colleague Sally showed in the
slide before it certainly is possible to
use an SQL light version but we only
recommend that for small labs that use a
single computer setup as soon as you're
moving to intercept read server setup we
highly recommend to use the SQL standard
or enterprise version
great thank you our next question is
would you please clarify whether the
data integrity features apply to a
single computer setup
um yes so
I'm not entirely sure of the questions
if I don't answer it here correctly
please send me an email afterwards but
the data integrity guideline actually
applied to all three setups this is
independent of the of the computer setup
great thank you is exported data right
protected
this depends on the on the format as
soon as you leaving the SQL database
you're obviously within the windows
level and windows file system so there
need to work with your IT department to
set the appropriate permissions what we
helped you with this we implemented
signed XML files so they have a checksum
so you can basically immediately see if
the file has been tempered with the
segment software has the ability to
basically check that in to import signed
XML file and we also give you the
opportunity to export PDF
you
great thank you all right your next
question is about autosave setting what
is the difference between softness six
and seven point one
the differences in 6.1 we did not have
to work the system though the autosave
setting is now tightly bound to the
workflow I basically went to back to
slide 15 so autosave in seven point one
is defined that
the scientist can decide if he wants to
set it up or not if he set the auto safe
he can either define the file name and
the storage location or either of those
but in general the scientist basically
defines where the file will be saved and
under which name you're able to add
either a number a date or a time which
will automatically basically them be
updated in order to differentiate the
different files but as soon as the
lateritic
opens up the middle the green protocol
it will be automatically saved so this
is the meaning of all of things and what
you were used to in the versus before is
now called auto export so on on an
enclosing event of the file if the
content of the file changed the copy of
the document will be automatically
exported out of the database and you can
essentially define as many locations and
as many file formats you want to have
exported on a file closure event this
applies it to the right side of
great thank you all right the next
question is will we get a copy of this
webinar presentation when completed
yes so what we will provide you for
download is a more complete presentation
so this is the the obviously
presentation version but we also send
out version that contains all the
information I was now basically verbally
communicating to you on the right side
and we want you to get the full version
so you can basically read up on on
everything ok great thank you all right
your next question is has molecular
devices consulted EU GMP compliance and
not just FDA compliance for example you
annex 11 and 15 MHRA data integrity
guidance or is the system and
qualification services only designed to
the u.s. not au compliance
so the system has been designed in a way
that you can set it up to be compliant
with the u.s. system D U and also with
the majority of the own guidelines in
the Asian region like Japan China these
the there are differences certainly but
most of the differences can be addressed
with the Commission's as well as the
parameters in some experince experiment
so the system itself is not compliant it
gives you the opportunity to basically
build a compliance system because there
are a lot of variables in there but the
system is fully capable of being set up
in a compliant way and as I said the
difference is in between the individual
regions they they can be fully addressed
with this version
thank you does the software now allow
identification of the instrument serial
number being used to collect the data
very good I see we have a lot of
experience users here in the audience so
for the newer instruments we do have the
option to actually have that included
for the older instruments such as the
Imperius that would require a firmware
update if you absolutely need that we
can refer you to our customs department
but um we don't have it in the pipeline
currently but new readers are capable of
you
great thank you all right your next
question is is the export function the
only way to interact with an L IMF
system or is there a direct integration
communication through L imsl IMS system
possible if we would export and import
it always by hand this would have
another review step for each import into
L IMS a gonna are gonna have to reread
the question here
experts ok no problem ok
at this point we don't have direct way
to interact with lymph system as there
is a pretty large variety of flavors out
there but we are looking into improving
this interface so if whoever asked this
question can sent me email I'm more than
happy to include areas opticspro insider
program I can work with them to
basically look at his requirements and
see what we can do in one of the future
versions
great alright your next question is with
the test place and the new software is
there an intention to bracket the entire
qualified linear range of the instrument
you
I think what this one we're gonna have
to fill up because I'm not sure if I
Sally do you yeah I would agree with you
if the person who asked that question
will be kind enough to submit an email
to Tom or to myself then we will be
happy to pick up with that because it's
about your user requirements more than
our standard system
great thank you
all right next question is what about
the backup and restoration of xql
database so for the single computer
setup we do provide a tool to backup the
SQL Express database for a larger
versions like SQL standard the IT
department typically already have set up
a backup system because we are not the
only ones using SQL databases they are
fairly standard and typically a key
apartment already have set up the backup
great thank you your next question is do
you expect a difference between five
point four and seven point one in terms
of rounding and changing final
reportable result
it is correct that has been a change in
rounding but in general this change is
in significant for most of the time and
if you move from like five point four to
version 7.1 we anyhow recommend
revalidation because not only do we
change the storage system from a Windows
file based system to SQL database but
also there has been so much development
in-between as we recommend the
revalidation for the protocols that are
still in use
thank you again Tom and Sally for your
time today in your important research we
would also like to thank lab roots and
our sponsor molecular devices for
underwriting today's educational web
cache before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
do not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speakers via
the contact information you provided at
the time of registration Labyrinth will
alert you via email when it's available
for replay and we encourage you to share
that email with your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event until
next time bye